una escapada al paraíso que salió muy
mal la ciudad de sanya apodada la hawai
de china ha sido una salida para miles
de turistas tras más de dos años de
estrictas restricciones por el cob y 19
en el país pero el retiro idílico de
hainán pronto se ha convertido en una
pesadilla para 80.000 turistas que ahora
están atrapados después de que las
autoridades confirmaran la isla kyle es
uno de ellos
la mayoría de los establecimientos y
lugares están cerrados el sur aire así
que no pudimos ver la asean y ven este
maestro que tiene su residencia en
shanghai estaba en sus primeras
vacaciones desde el comienzo de la
pandemia pero ahora necesita 5 pcr es
negativas en siete días antes de poder
abordar un vuelo de regreso a casa y es
sólo una de las muchas estrictas medidas
implementadas en la isla
en las áreas de alto riesgo los
residentes deben quedarse en casa y se
les entregará todo lo que necesitan en
la zona de riesgo medio las personas
deben permanecer en sus complejos y
deben recoger sus pedidos y las entradas
en diferentes horarios para evitar
aglomeraciones
las autoridades cancelaron todos los
vuelos y trenes en sanya durante el fin
de semana antes de extender el cierre a
otras ciudades en jaén han este lunes la
isla situada frente a la costa sur de
china ha tenido muy pocos casos de kobe
19 desde el comienzo de la pandemia pero
ha informado más de 1500 contagios este
mes